[Music]
and now far left climate Warrior and
that's congresswoman Alexandria
ocasio-cortez uh wasn't seeing much
green at the box office over the weekend
reportedly raking in an average of 80
bucks per theater for her climate
documentary to the end now the
documentary follows far left activists
as they try to get climate legislation
passed in Congress as it turns out the
climate cult's agenda may not be as
popular as Democrats in the media mob
and their allies there want you to think
because it appears the documentary is
going straight into the recycling bin
anyway here with more Louisiana Senator
John Kennedy is with us so if you look
at the number this movie grows less than
ten thousand dollars on its opening
weekend so you're averaging 80 bucks per
theater
out you don't have to be a mathematician
from MIT a Harvard Senator to figure out
here that this movie is a flop and a
disaster
um the question is what does that tell
us about the American people's attitude
towards climate alarmism
uh the movie about congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
Sean makes me appreciate
Elon Musk that much more
and here's what I mean by that uh the
the people who have made uh the
congresswoman's movie she had another
one before that was on Netflix or part
of what I call the media entertainment
industrial complex
they're not only entertainers I'm
including many digital newspapers many
paper newspapers many mainstream uh
television networks uh
these are folks who only present to the
American people one point of view
uh and that's the point of view of
congresswoman ocasio-cortez many of the
congresswoman supporters don't like
America they think America was wicked
when it was founded it's even more
wicked today they think the American
people or at least millions of them are
are racist and misogynistic and ignorant
ignorant many of these supporters of the
congresswoman assigned people to a
status they don't see us as individuals
that all white people for example they
think are racist uh all black people
they think are victims all women are
powerless they don't see us as
individuals that's why I appreciate what
Elon Musk has done so much he's taken a
very courageous stand for the First
Amendment
uh the man uh he he they they've they've
they're beating on him like he stole
Christmas
um but he he's tough he's tough as a
pine knot and and the man's got guts
he's got
he's got oranges the size of beach balls
and and and and and thanks thanks to
Elon Musk thanks to Elon Musk you're
right we're we're gonna have to get some
new conspiracy theories because the old
ones turned out all to be truth
they told us they told us that they
weren't censoring on Twitter
um and that it was all a conspiracy
theory well Elon Musk has demonstrated
otherwise and I just said a tip of the
hat to him the worst thing they did is
the FBI was meeting with every big tech
company weekly in the lead up to the
2020 election warning them well you
might have hacked materials there might
be a disinformation campaign from
foreign adversaries uh if you see
anything on Hunter Biden for example
it's probably not true you're not going
to want to disseminate that information
isn't that the FBI putting their thumb
on the scout of a presidential election
weeks outside of that election and
doesn't it sound like they put their
thumb on the scale in 2016 as well how
often is the FBI going to be influencing
the outcome of our presidential
elections
well I think I think director Ray
um has a lot of explaining to to do to
the American people should he be fired
for not cleaning this up
I don't know who's right or wrong but I
think director Ray to preserve the
Integrity of the FBI and I think most
FBI agents are fine people but clearly
their leadership at times has been
lacking and I think director Ray needs
to call a press conference or come
before Congress and in front of God
country and the American people explain
what all this means because this stuff
I'm just going to say these emails on
Twitter that have been revealed they
ought to make every Democrat every
Republican in America who believes in
the First Amendment gag
you know senator now have a little bone
to pick with Republicans in your body
the U.S Senate uh there's been five
occasions since 1954 where the gavel has
changed hands from one party to another
uh never before under those
circumstances has the Congress or in
this case the Senate ever gone forward
with an Omnibus spending bill right now
you've called this by the way Omnibus
spending porn I think you're right I
want you to explain the term but now we
have Republicans willing to go along
with Chuck Schumer and the radical
Democrats and give them a year-long
budget when all they should be doing is
passing a CR continuing resolution so
that when the new house Republican
leaderships gets in power there'll be a
check and balance against the insane
amount of spending that's going on in
Washington now why would your Republican
colleagues be going along with this
madness
well you're gonna have to ask those who
end up going along with it this is what
I told my Republican and Democratic
colleagues two weeks ago
I think to to get control of inflation
we have to reduce the rate of spending
growth growth and debt accumulation
that's my goal in passing a budget and I
told the proponents of the Omnibus that
they're going to have to demonstrate to
me given my goal that they can get a
better deal working with the Democrats
in an Omnibus than waiting for a
republican majority in the house that's
what they're going to have to show to me
now I'm on the Appropriations Committee
I don't have the slightest idea what's
in the Omni Omnibus Nobody Does the the
Omnibus almost always contains what I
call spending porn and a lot of
extraneous features I'm not I want to
see the bill but they've got to prove to
me we can get a better deal doing it
this way than waiting on the House
Majority uh or the Republican majority
in the house and that's a heavy burden
to carry and they've got to prove it to
me otherwise I'm gonna vote no uh
there's no way they can prove that to
you you know it and I Know It And any
Republican that goes along with this is
is buying into Democratic Madness it's
really I I can't believe the lack of
understanding of what a republican
majority in the house means to spending
and they should be thinking of all of
this on their own and not needing a talk
show host uh to remind them Senator good
to see you my friend merry Christmas
thank you Sean you too hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else